meet the masked birch caterpillar if we
poke his leaf watch what he does with
his rear end
he's scraping it across the leaf
producing vibrations to warn us off his
territory
one idea about how these communication
signals evolved is that they are
ritualized versions of everyday
activities so the crickets song made by
rubbing the Rings together evolved from
sound produced when fluttering the wings
for flight to test this idea researchers
from Carleton University in Ottawa
staged territorial caterpillar bouts in
their lab the caterpillars they study
built silken leaf shelters to protect
themselves from predators and the
elements while they feed watch what
happens when an intruder arrives first
our caterpillar drums is mandibles then
he combines mandible drumming with
scraping eventually this noisy display
drives the unwelcome visitor away the
key to the evolution of this bizarre
behavior lies in the caterpillars rear
end scraping structure it's called the
anal or and it's very similar to another
structure the anal pro-league but other
species use for walking take a look at
this caterpillar walking with pro legs
now look how the masked birch
caterpillar scrapes
instead of moving forward he uses his
oar to walk on the spot to talk it's
likely that these signals evolved to
avoid costly physical fights scraping
derived from crawling towards an
intruder and noisy mandible drumming is
probably a ritualized form of more
aggressive behavior like biting and
pushing courts have this caterpillar
without anal AWS repelled an intruder
he's defending his shelter by pushing
and hitting the intruder the masked
birch caterpillar avoiding a physical
confrontation relies on his noisy leaf
shaking display to drive trespasses away
you